(techno music)
- [Voiceover] What is it?
- [Voiceover] An extremely sick cat.
- What's up guys, my name
is Curly and I am obsessed
with my ratings score
on Uber as a passenger.
So we're gonna ask a bunch of drivers
what they find annoying
so that I can make sure
to avoid those things so
I can keep that score.
What would you say would
make you rate somebody
less than a five?
- Sometimes people might
get in and they're drunk
and they're demanding
and they just want me
to do exactly what they wanna do.
That's probably the most annoying thing.
- Do you ever get people
that get your face
or touch you or kind of do too much?
- No, they can tell that
I'll slap fuck out of them.
(laughs)
- Especially when they're
drunk, they're drinking
and they don't know where they're going.
They tell you to use Waze
while I have Google here.
Waze is sometime in rush
hour is more difficult.
- I'm honestly fine with wet or dry food,
I just like playing hard to feed.
- Echo friendly!
Ones.
- Just don't be a backseat driver.
- And being demanding,
I think that's rude.
Because there's a way to talk to people.
- Drunk customers they don't
know where they're going
are sometime, whatever
they're saying they won't
make a sense, you know?
- Just give us a tip and
they say it'll charge.
- [Voiceover] Cavon Laessig,
good day or bad day?
- It was a great day.
- [Voiceover] Why?
- Started out with the main governer
giving a press conference apologizing
for really dumb things he
said that were pretty racist
and then digging the hole deeper.
Beyonce keeps popping up everywhere.
She is going to be in the
Super Bowl halftime show,
and she's also on the Channing
Tatum lip-sync battle,
that was a big deal.
I'm so out of breath,
everything's so exciting.
Manatees are on the rebound.
it's true, they're no longer endangered.
Also, great jobs numbers.
I'm just so winded
right now, and so happy.